so we walk into the restaurant and we
get to meet nori's black book
she is everything and more everything
and more but we
i was convinced it was someone that we
knew and it's
not kim kardashian and khloe kardashian
finally uncovered who runs nori's black
book on
instagram it's really lit and fun and
crazy
the sisters played detective on keeping
up with the kardashians
trying to figure out who is behind
nori's black book on instagram
a parody account inspired by kim and
kanye west's daughter northwest
with a whopping 1 million followers has
anyone ever wondered
who nori's black book is oh i wonder it
all the time
like she is so witty it's literally
north
talking nori's black book is
the funniest instagram account ever nori
talks from the voice of northwest her
perspective her perspective of what she
thinks
north is like and when i tell you and
what we think north is spot on
that is exactly who north is kim and
chloe kick off their investigation by
questioning their
inner circle i'm gonna figure it all out
i promise you including celeb
hairstylist jen
atkin and kim's former assistant
stephanie shepherd
are you nori's black book i wish it was
joy's black book my captions aren't that
good
who i think it is who that no
i'm calling her right now we're on the
case
we have a serious question to ask you
are you
nori's black book i wish i was
why is that everyone's answer i think
it's really someone random because i
don't think any of your guys's friends
are that funny
no no one is that funny i would i agree
i would hang out with them all the
time after they denied being the account
kim went full
on fbi reaching out to the chief
marketing officer of her kkw
brands who suggested messaging the
account about sending over a kkw
beauty press box so they could get their
home address
yeah that's a good idea if this works we
might finally get our answer well
their plan worked meet natalie franklin
the creator behind your favorite
kardashian memes
i started it literally like seven years
ago and i'm on the phone with my friends
when the
baby's rs collection came out and you
weren't showing north's face yet
just her body and i'm on the phone and
i'm like god norrish would be so [ __ ]
pissed like
can you imagine being northwest and
you're wearing babies r us like
the nerve and then just like a light
bulb went off natalie explained that the
handle is inspired by north's nickname
and kim and kanye's love for the color
black kind of build her personality off
kim's how direct she is with all of you
and then kanye is like it's kind of like
okay if you think kanye has the ego you
think kim's a little direct like
northwest and on thursday kim shared
this snap from their meetup on instagram
writing in part quote meet natalie aka
nori's black book who started that
account for fun
and is spot on with north's personality
it's all in fun and so happy we got to
meet the super talented hysterical
writer
natalie the legend right in front of us
of course this season marks the 20th and
final season of keeping up
and after cameras documented the moment
the famous family told their longtime
crew the news
chloe had them all vowed to make the
last month of filming
one for the books we have about a month
left of filming
and i just think we should make the best
of it let's make it so fun
and let's create some badass memories as
for the kardashians decision to walk
away from the show
shortly after news broke in september
that keeping up would be coming to an
end et spoke to the show's executive
producer ryan seacrest
and he opened up about what a tough call
it was for the family to make
in talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make and
and i know even you know before and
after the announcement came out
they were emotional we were trading
texts and emails after the announcement
uh and you look back at 14 years and 20
seasons of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it but they'll be
back on tv soon
the family inked a major new deal with
[Music]
hulu
you